vendredi ou les limbes du pacifique par
michel tournier à nouveau robinson mais
un nouveau robinson qui respecte les
règles du jeu oui parce que à la suite
de daniel dufau qui a écrit ce roman au
début du xviiie siècle
il ya eu d'innombrables versions
nouvelles de robinson crusoé et il y en
a qui sont des chefs-d'oeuvre
considérables comme par exemple sujets
sains et le pacifique de jean giraudoux
y en a qui ont eu un retentissement
pedro une femme une jeune fille
il y en a qui ont eu un retentissement
énorme comme le robinson suis sûr que
c'est toute une famille qui débarque
dans une île est alors comment élever
des enfants dans une île n'est ce pas
est tout de même ses auteurs ont pris
des libertés considérable avec le cadre
qui avaient été définis par daniel defoe
à savoir le xviiie siècle l'île dans le
pacifique
robinson un anglais n'est ce pas
l'ombrelle le chien vendredi qui arrive
par la suite
pour ma part je me suis efforcé de
respecter ce cadre général il ya quand
robinson débarque en deux mots gallo
metz c'est un anglais c'est un peu
optimiste je t il s'aperçoit qu'il est
sur une île déserte
c'est un jeune anglais puritains avare
méthodique qui était parti pour faire
fortune dans le nouveau monde
car ça situe à l'époque où les les
anglais sont en train de faire le
nouveau monde n'est ce pas avec une
morale protestante qui est la leur et
qui est la morale précapitaliste lettre
la morale capitaliste
il a lu franklin sa philosophie est
celle de benjamin franklin le bonhomme
franklin celui du du cerf-volant
électriques etc
et c'est une morale tout à fait
étonnante qu'il faut lire dans les
halles manade de benjamin où il explique
que le bien ça consiste à gagner de
l'argent et le mal dépensé mais ce qu'il
faut accumuler accumuler c'est une
morale essentiellement du travail pour
le travail avec cette morale dans la
tête je peux dire j'aimerais que
initié ce que comme en rebat sont change
peu à peu plus comment il ne se situe
pas ça à sept îles
avec la qualité via le budget de vivre
et comment il s'en détourner comment il
la prend ensuite oui robinson c'est
avant tout est ce pas le drame de la
solitude
il s'aperçoit qu'il est tout seul au
début il croyait qu'il y avait des
survivants il nous fallait y en a pas il
est tout seul alors sa première réaction
est une réaction de fuite
il refuse cette solitude et au lieu de
se tourner vers l'île et se tourne vers
la mer il attend qu'on vienne le
chercher et il a l'impression que tout
ce qu'il fera pour aménager sa solitude
pour s'installer diminuera ses chances
qu'on vienne le chercher c'est magique
mais ces normes
c'est normal le résultat ne se fait pas
attendre
c'est la déchéance ils mangent n'importe
quoi il ne s'habillent plus il ne marche
plus sur ses jambes qui se traînent par
terre n'est ce pas et alors la souille
la souille c'est une mare n'est ce pas
qui a été brassée par les pécaris
comment en france dans tous les pays
d'europe par les sangliers n'est ce pas
qui devient une espèce de fange et dans
laquelle les pécaris s'enfonce pendant
toute la journée où il fait très chaud
et les moustiques en ne laissant passer
que leur goût - n'est-ce pas c'est très
agréable
robinson découvre ça il fait comme eux
et alors ils passent des journées
entières dans la soude les émanations
délétère le rendent un peu fou et il
oublie
il n'a pas trop chaud il n'y a pas de
moustiques et surtout ce qui est la
grande différence
il retourne en arrière il se replonge
dans son passé il revit son enfance à
york n'est ce pas chez son père chez sa
mère avec les frères et soeurs jusqu'au
jour où on touche du doigt le danger
qu'il menace qui la folie et la mort car
il entend de la musique un jour qu'il
était dans la souille il dit je suis
mort ce sont les enjeux sont pas du tout
irie voit apparaître un navire qui
arrive il se précipite qui fait des
signes à spa ce navire est un galion un
galion espagnol ce qui est déjà étrange
parce que c'est un bateau qu'on ne voit
plus depuis deux siècles déjà en plus
d'une foule chamarré à bord avec des
musiciens d une table chargée de
vaisselle splendide et comble
d'extraordinaire ce navire long
le rivage de l'île et n'aborde pas les
robinson pour rappel c'est le navire
sans vent c'est le délire celle d il
s'aperçoit sont là qu'il a des
hallucinations et qu'il est perdu
alors ils se tournent vers l'est alors à
ce moment là il fait demi tour et dont
le doigt la mer il assume sa solitude et
il se tourne vers lui il accepte ville
il épouse nil et c'est alors à ce
moment-là benjamin franklin qui l'habite
qui l'habite n'est ce pas ce mais a
explosé il administre c'est la période
de vide administré seul mais il ne veut
pas s'arrêter là ministre et le heat
avec le monde
il édicte des lois il ya un code pénal
il ya un code civil et il construit des
maisons pas seulement une maison pour
lui mais il ya un temple une paierie
générale il ya des fortifications il se
nomme général se nomme gouverneur et
plus de puni bas exemple à quoi cela va
t il ya une des liens des punitions
la punition c'est la fausse la fosse
c'est une fausse qui se trouve en plein
soleil et qui est en quelque sorte
inverse de la souille espace est sec et
c'est au soleil est là il s'inflige des
jours de fausses dans la mesure où il a
succombé à la tentation de la soupe
parce que quelquefois tout de même hissé
fondre et il retourne vers la succession
vis c'est ça s'arrête de travailler le
samedi après midi
c'est ça il ya un dimanche thé chaud
mais qui remplit d'obligations dominical
n'est ce pas il ya la bible il faut dire
le seul livre qu'il a sauvée du naufrage
c'est la bible alors ils se se nourrit
de la bible et il ya le dimanche il ya
des inaugurations officielles mais se
construit une villa pour le dimanche
il se construit une villa pour le
dimanche et ça devient monstrueux il ne
peut pas s'arrêter car ils ont le
sentiment que s'il s'arrête il va
retomber sous x c'est le problème du
capitalisme est pas dupe un capitalisme
qui doit toujours produire en espaçant
araki bien que lorsque vendredi arrive
lille est florissant les premiers les
florissante mais monstrueuse elle tourne
à vide et lorsque robinson voir arriver
ce jeune sauvage il dit enfin voilà la
justification de tous c'est le sujet
idéal n'est ce pas et il en fait le
second tour quand il est général c'est
un simple soldat
quand il est administrateur c'est son
valet quand il est prêtre c'est l'enfant
de choeur n'est ce pas et vendredi se
plie tant bien que mal à cet ordre
après tout en remerciant est lui a sauvé
la vie et puis n'y comprend rien par
lynn y comprend rien et puis sous cette
source est sous cette apparence
soumission il ya une révolte malgré nuit
n'est ce pas fleury fait des
catastrophes jeunesse vous avez conservé
à vendredi sa nature et sarah sa nature
oui oui c'est un indien
c'est un art au camp c'est à dire un
indien venus du var et du chili centrale
de métis et un peu métisser les [ __ ]
parce que j'ai voulu souligner la
réaction raciste de de robinson qui
d'ailleurs nettement indiqué chez chez
daniel de faux il voit arriver cet homme
c'est non seulement un homme de couleur
au singulier mais d'un homme de couleur
au pluriel danse est un [ __ ] plus un
indien c'est à dire vraiment rien c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il lui donne pas
un entretien il appelle vendredi
en attendant mieux on verra si s'il a
une âme plus qu'à le mot d'ailleurs que
robinson prononce d'après de flou à ce
moment là oui ça j'ai posé le maître
parce que c'était nord la de faux il ya
vingt ans qu'il est tout seul il ya
vingt ans qu'ils aient tous il a failli
devenir fou de solitude l'angoissé a
pris à la gorge
il a hurlé pour avoir un compagnon au
bout de 20 ans arrive vendredi
que va-t-il dire sous la plume de daniel
devaud dieu m'envoie un domestique et
lui fait cirer ses votes
c'est une énormité est tout à fait dans
la ligne dure bassan de daniel defoe et
les deux membres vincent première
manière
j'ai pas osé de m c'est être en gros
j'ai peur qu'on ne croie pas d'héritier
la révolte qui se manifestent bruyamment
dérouille amant il fait des catastrophes
n'est ce pas et menacent e-menaces il
administré est tellement quinze jours
n'est ce pas en fumant secrètement parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de fumer mais
ils fument secrètement la pipe de roma
sont dans la grotte où robinson
accumuler tous les barils de poudre qui
l'a sauvée du naufrage
il fait tout sauter toute l'île
administrés sauter un incendie qui
détruit le reste est finalement robinson
se retrouve seul avec vendredi il repart
à zéro avec vendredi et alors cette fois
c'est vendredi qu'il sait vendre
guerrier le kilomètre c'est vendredi qui
lui apprend comment on vit dans une île
déserte
et que devient vendredi qu'affirme
vendredi alors à ce moment là n'est ce
pas la solitude qui a et opérer une
espèce d'érosion sur robinson la chèvre
et robinson devient élémentaire au sens
des éléments bruts l'eau la terre
le soleil et robinson s'aperçoit que
tout en étant administrateur paysans il
est l'homme de la terre essentiellement
et que vendredi si on le laisse faire
le léger vendredi le guet et
primesautier vendredi c'est l'homme de
l'air et ils développent n'est ce pas
les attributs aérien et robinson
l'observent il laisse libre cette fois
et vous à vendredi qui se met à tailler
des flèches extraordinaire des flèches
qu'ils n'atterrissent plus n'est-ce pas
il envoie des flèches vers le haut vers
le ciel en espérant qu'elle n'a terrien
plus jamais et puis ensuite il tue un
bouc et avec sa peau il fait un
cerf-volant
c'est la deuxième c'est pas le deuxième
attributs aérien de raoni et puis
ensuite il construit avec les boyaux du
bouc une harpe éolienne et la harpe
éolienne espace d'une musique très
importante parce que c'est une musique
d'éléments c'est le vent et fait de la
musique et levante qui joue est pas de
l'arpp
c'est à dire vraiment là le côté
élémentaire et aériens d'avoir laissé
exprimer complètement mais robinson va
redevenir toute l'affairé en rien ce que
l'homme de la terre ne peut pas devenir
l'homme de l'air aussi facilement alors
il ya un moyen terme c'est le soleil et
robinson se tournent de plus en plus
vers le soleil il devient un être
solaire un héros solaire il ya des
extases solaire n'est ce pas et il
devient un héros tels que certains héros
mythologiques
n'est ce pas un peu long et puis
peut-être même certains certains
certaines personnes moderne ce pas
justement vous dit et on le pense en le
lisant comme à son est un personnage
moderne assez sa frappe et c'est ce qui
m'a frappé c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs
j'ai écrit ce livre
robinson c'est l'homme de la solitude
c'est l'homme du bricolage faites le
vous même
n'est ce pas c'est l'homme de avec
vendredi le problème du racisme
le problème du colonialisme le problème
de la vie à deux tel que par exemple il
se pose puisque logiquement pendant les
cellules gemini on en voit deux hommes
il faut qu'ils ne s'entraînent gorge pas
au bout de trois jours n'est ce pas ça
pose un problème psychologique
et puis alors c'est l'homme du soleil
c'est l'homme de la vie au soleil
aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas les vacances
c'est le soleil c'est là la plage
le ban soleil qui est une chose
difficile dur pénible c'est une ascèse
le même soleil ça fait mal pourquoi
parce qu'on veut être bronzé on veut
être un héros solaire en métal c'est la
jeunesse inaltérable le bain de soleil
puis un second de perversion aussi alors
il ya le problème évidemment des
problèmes de la sexualité qui n'avait
pas été abordée par daniel de fou et je
crois aujourd'hui on ne peut pas ne pas
l'aborder
que devient la sexualité d'un homme qui
restent seuls 20 ans moi je pense et je
crois que c'est conforme la psychologie
actuelle que la sexualité de l'homme
mois normal étant essentiellement
sociales n'ont pas biologique mais
sociale c'est à dire une construction
qui provient de tout ce que nous avons
appris au cinéma dans les romans ce que
nous avons entendu une tradition n'est
ce pas et qui nous a donné une espèce
d'échafaudages psychique qui est notre
sexualité et bien si on retire la
société ces défis cet échafaudage
s'effondre mais on couche avec des
fleurs alors à ce moment là on peut
faire n'importe quoi et c'est ce que
fait et c'est ce que faire en passant il
ya plusieurs formes de sa sexualité qui
évolue n'est ce pas une sexualité
terrestre il ya une sexualité clora la
rs3 floral
on n'a pas parlé du chien à le chien est
très important parce que pendant les
vingt ans ou robinson a été tout seul
sans vendredi ils n'avaient que le chien
est pas le chien ten
alors oui non je voudrais surtout que
vous disiez ce soit quoi tu n as servi
par particulièrement un jour un moment
oui il ya le problème du feu le
l'épisode du sourire est pas un jour
robinson se regarde dans une glace et il
ne se reconnaît pas et pourtant rien n'a
changé dans son usage ne se reconnaît
pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé il dit
j'ai un visage de glace mon visage est
mort et il essaie de sourire
il n'y parvient pas et il s'aperçoit
qu'on les comprend à ce moment là que le
visage de chacun de nous a besoin pour
vivre
d autres autrui est un être qui modèle
qui donne sa vie à notre visage sans
autrui notre visage meurt c'est comme un
feu sur lequel il faudrait que tout le
monde souffle à tour de rôle pour qu'ils
brûlent sinon il s'éteint alors erbatons
s'apercevant qu'il a perdu cette faculté
du sourire qui est quand même chose très
importante pour l'être humain est pris
d'un désespoir profond il dit me manque
rien dans cette île j'ai la bible je
peux manger tout ce qu'il faut mais quel
est le compagnon qui me rendre à la
faculté de sourire et leur il regarde
autour de lui il a un qui fait le tour
de l'île jusqu'au moment où il
s'aperçoit que son chien est assis à
côté de lui le regarde et sourit il a la
tête un petit peu tourné sa lèvre n'est
ce pas se relève sur ses crocs n'est ce
pas il est sept sourire et ça je n'ai
pas inventé il ya des chiens qui sourit
oui et à partir de ce moment là c'est
comme un jeu entre robinson et le chien
de temps en temps province on regarde le
chien d'une certaine façon et le chien
comprend il lui donne une leçon de
sourire et robinson se penche sur la
tête du chien et hissant sa phase qui se
dégèle peu à peu au contact de ce
compagnon à quatre pattes je remercie
michel tournier très beau roman de
michel tournier chez gallimard vendredi
ou les limbes du pacifique
on
ouais
demont